- On this episode, we
have a ton of guests,
and we go dark, and we go high.
(rhythmic hip-hop instrumental music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and you're watching episode 12
of the #AskGaryVee show.
Fun fact for episode 12, the number 12,
the number of the
hall-of-famer Joe Namath,
the greatest quarterback
in New York Jets history.
It's good to be back, let's get to it.
- [Voiceover] Digi-talk
asks, as a freelancer,
should you ever work for exposure only?
- Mary, congrats on being the, by the way,
the first person to
get two questions asked
on the #AskGaryVee show, and I know,
I know I'm gonna see in the comments,
everybody's gonna be like,
you haven't even answered mine yet,
and now you've answered
Mary's second question?
Yes.
She asks good questions.
But, this question, I really wanna answer
because I've been having a lot of
Twitter conversations
lately, and very honestly
for the basic eight to 10 years
that I've been in the tech game,
meeting all these wonderful people,
especially when you
think about the tech game
when I first got into it, it was a very,
save the world and much more zen,
it was less business-y.
Characters like me probably ruined it.
(thumping)
This is a big debate, this
is something that I sit
on a very firm line on,
which is, I do think
that people should do things
for free, for exposure.
I still do things for free.
And I get very compensated for my time,
and my efforts, and I still do it,
and somebody will say,
I had an easier base,
people have to pay the bills.
But the fact that people
don't take into account
that there is strategy in
doing things for exposure,
that then lead to bigger
money in the future.
This is not about elitism, like
some people jump on Twitter
and say, pay the people!
You gotta pay for the quality of work!
I agree.
But one needs to understand
that money is not the only way to pay.
Giving people in an at-bat, the platform,
the exposure, is an absolute monetary way
to compensate them in the
way that I define monetary.
Listen, by the way, you
might fully disagree with me,
and that's 'cause you've
gone romantic on the issue,
in my POV, and I respect that.
But I just don't know a
single person that is deemed,
has achieved success without doing
a solid percentage of things for free,
as a jockeying chess
move to their success.
So if you're asking me, the answer's yes.
If you don't do it, and
you only pay to play,
I get it.
And, by the way, it ebb and flows.
I now respond to many of you,
no I cannot speak at this
event unless I get my fee,
because I promised my
wife I will not travel
without getting my fee, because
I've got two young kids,
this and that, and so like, it changes.
You know, I will not be sold by anybody
that it is inappropriate
to do some spec work,
because I really believe in its strategy.
- What's up Gary, it's Mitch Schneider,
and I've got a question for you.
The company I'm working
for has a great story.
We're putting up great content
on all our social channels,
but we're not seeing the
engagement we were hoping for.
Is it worth it to promote
our Facebook posts,
our tweets, and our LinkedIn posts,
in order to gain more engagement
on what we're putting out there?
What do you think, are they worth it?
- I think they're worth it.
Now, I think they're
worth it if you actually
target it properly.
So you used promote,
and I would say, target.
Meaning, Twitter, you
can target actual words
that people are using
to get even more narrow
into who you're trying to target.
Facebook dark posts, we've ad nauseam
talked over these 12 episodes,
of Facebook dark posts.
I do think you should target, but,
and this is why I turned
my face to the camera
while you were asking
a question my friend,
you're deeming it to be great content.
Maybe it just isn't.
Right, and I think that
that's a dangerous thing
that a lot of people really
need to figure out, which is,
you may feel good of how it looks,
but the reason I wrote Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook is,
is it contextually proper?
Does it have the right hashtags?
Is it linking properly?
Do you have the right amount of length?
Are the pictures proper?
Are you putting the logos in
the right spots within it?
Please triple check,
you gotta check yourself
before you wreck yourself, they say,
and so please triple check,
that you're checking all the boxes
of doing all that stuff properly.
Number two, I do believe
that if you can afford,
if you're lucky enough, and
a lot of people watching
aren't lucky enough, but
if you're lucky enough
to have the resources to target a segment,
and boost up its awareness.
If that content is good, that is gonna
spread like fire for
you, and it's gonna pay
much bigger dividends long-term, so,
I am a fan of it.
- [Voiceover] Erick asks,
what's the last new skill
you learned as a result
of taking an interest
in someone else's passion, hobby, or job?
- Erick, this is a really
interesting question.
I'm tryin' to figure this out.
You know, one that's
emerging, a little bit,
believe it or not, but I'm
not gonna accept it, is golf.
A.J. has fallen in love with golf, my bro.
And, you know, I don't know
if I'm picking up a skill,
but I guess I am a little
bit, I'm out there.
I've been thinking, should I get into it?
I just can't commit to the five hours
that it takes to play, and so, I'm scared.
People get addicted with golf, so,
that would've been the
answer, but I've been luckily
able to hold off that
insanity of the golf drug.
I would probably say, and
this is a weird answer,
I'd probably say respecting data.
You know, I think that
I believe in targeting,
and big data, and all
this new digital stuff
because Eric Caster and John Casmanus
when they started
VaynerMedia as developers,
showed me the other side of marketing,
which was retargeting, and CRMs,
and all these things, and so,
that was probably the last skill
that I remember really picking up.
Yeah, I would say respecting data.
- [Voiceover] John asks,
when you're in a funk,
what do you do to get out of it?
- John, you've asked a
question that I've been
really excited to share with the world,
because it works, it is very dark.
Like, this is dark, so,
I know that most people
when they share my content say, beware,
potty mouth McGee.
This one's beware, you
may be like, frightened,
with a little bit of like a teardrop
on your left eye.
Left.
(thumping)
I'm gonna tell you the truth,
because that was the commitment
when I decided to do this,
which, you know, obviously I'm able,
well Steve's curating the questions
but I could always kibosh them, so,
when I start doing these live,
or when we do live events,
or we take this show on the road
and it's audience participation
then it'll really be
the full monty but for now,
I'm answering them and I'm
answering them truthfully.
This is a dark one, I'm
stalling 'cause it's dark.
It's dark.
When I'm in a funk, I
literally close my eyes,
put myself into a place where,
something remarkable happens to me.
You know,
CNN names me the greatest man of all time.
You know, just literally
like silly things like,
I get on a list of being
the best entrepreneurs,
or, Birchbox sells for
four billion dollars
and I make a lot of money, or,
the full extreme, when
I'm in my most funk,
I literally try, usually I
do things that are realistic,
and happen within a one-year window.
But in my deepest funks, I'll project,
this is harder, this is
a little more role play,
'cause when I think about stuff
that's gonna happen,
intimately, it feels real.
But I'll dream about buying the Jets.
And I'll think about those great things,
and then I literally,
I literally make pretend
that Birchbox sells,
that I make millions
and millions of dollars,
and that that's the phone call,
and the next phone call is
from my hysterical sister
telling me that my mother
died in a car accident.
And I really do that.
And I really go there.
And it very, like,
I'm very, as you guys know me,
I'm an emotional character.
I go there, and it really does
something interesting for me.
I really don't care that I
made seven million dollars,
if my mom died.
I just really don't.
And I can, even as I'm
telling you this right now,
I can feel it, I can truly feel
how little I care about that,
in comparison to what I
would feel with that pain,
and very honestly, it
just sets me straight.
It just reminds me what my priorities are,
and it allows me to
understand that the health
of my children or my wife, I mean,
the fear and the shivers
I get when I think about
their passing, in, you know,
in real live, like them dying.
And it just sets me so straight.
It just makes me realize,
how non-important losing that client was,
or that best employee, or that
deal, or that opportunity.
Passing on Uber, in the first round,
which would have given
me 100 million dollars.
In paper, so they gotta go public.
But it's pretty damn in there.
Is something I can deal with, because,
the truth is, it's just
not what makes me happy.
And more importantly, I'm so happy
that everybody I love has
been healthy for so long,
losing grandparents early
has put me in that position,
so a negative is a positive,
and that's what I do.
I go in a very strange cocoon,
and make pretend that
people I love the most die.
- Gary Vee,
Amy S.
Savvysexysocial.com,
maybe you remember me, hi!
- Of course.
- My question is, I'm finding
that the more I travel,
more events I go to,
it's like this major
intensity constant high
of meeting people, and great content,
and it's like so insane.
And then I come home to
like, total normalness.
And sometimes that is
such a drastic change,
that it actually feels low,
when it's not actually that low,
it's actually just normal.
But you're just coming down
from such a consistent high
of being at a five-day
conference, and it's like, crazy.
How do you stay level,
between all these events that you do,
because you actually instill
the intensity in people
when you go speaking and
all that kind of stuff.
I'm just trying to find some
balance in my life, Gary.
Trying to find the balance,
I think you've got it.
I think you got it.
Help me out!
- Amy, you've got me pegged.
I do have it.
I am equally as fired up sitting by myself
on a six-hour flight in an airplane,
as I am speaking in front of 7000 people,
being the person that is the
Puff Daddy of that event,
which is the hype artist.
Yeah, yeah.
And so,
you know I'm not sure,
maybe it's very similar
to the question that we just did.
I do have that balance
because I'm thankful for
what is in front of me.
I very much live in the moment.
One of my flaws, and/or my gifts,
is that I'm so into what
I'm doing, of that moment,
that I do forget about my
family, or my responsibilities,
'cause I'm so zoned in.
Right now I'm literally could
care less of what's going on
with anything outside this cube,
'cause I'm zoned into
the #AskGaryVee show.
So I'm very all in on what I'm doing,
and so when I come back from that high,
first of all I'm pretty
much high, although, I mean,
I can create high from calm if I need it,
'cause I'm hyped.
And excited.
Yeah, I know, I don't,
this is an answer that's very difficult.
I wanted to show this answer
because I appreciate the question,
'cause I think a lot of
people think about it.
But the truth is, this
is something that comes
very natural to me. It's intuitive.
I would just ask all of you,
and I talk a lot about this,
I tweeted out quite a bit
over the last two weeks
about my grateful kind of post on Medium.
I think gratitude, Amy.
I mean, just be grateful,
be grateful that you have
some down time and it's
just normal, and it's nice,
and you get to see your
core friends and family,
and be very grateful
that you're lucky enough
to go to five-day tech raves,
where you can be on that high.
- [Voiceover] Duke asks, what
would you say A.J. has learned
and applied from you in business, and,
would he be willing to answer
this question on the show?
- Duke, memo alert.
This is the #AskGaryVee show.
This is not the Ask A.J.
Vee show with no silent E's.
This is my show, I answer the questions.
There is no A.J. answering the questions.
It's me, I do it, it's my show.
Take it away, bro.
- Duke, thanks so much for the question.
It's a really good one, and
one that I could probably
spend a couple of hours talking through,
but I know this show
is long enough already.
Tryin' to think through it, like I said,
there's a lot I could go through.
I think one of the biggest
things is perspective.
I think that, in the course of
growing a business very fast,
there's a lot that gets thrown at you.
And there's a lot of good,
and there's a lot of bad.
And it's really keeping
the highs not too high,
and the lows not too low.
And really taking a step back,
thinking about the wider impact
of everything that's happening and really,
just not stressing yourself out too much.
I think every day goes by, a lot happens,
but you can really just
focus on what's important,
think about the big picture.
That's been massively beneficial for me
as we've grown the business
together at Vayner.
Another huge one for me, is just the value
of the team and HR.
And just really focusing on personalizing
the experience with your staff.
I think, you know, when focusing on HR,
I think there's a temptation
to be a little bit
too by-the-book, you
know follow a process,
a handbook, of how to handle reviews,
and how to handle situations,
and we very much take a
look at every situation
that comes our way, with
anybody that we work with.
And really personalize
that, and really think
about the situation and the impact of it.
And don't use a cookie cutter system.
I think just really
focusing on HR, you know,
we grew very fast at Vayner,
we went through a spurt, of,
roughly, from 12
employees to 25 employees,
to 100 to 250 to 400.
And when you're growing that fast,
I think the two things
that I've mentioned:
really keeping perspective
and big-picture thoughts,
and really making sure that
you're focusing on the team,
and the team within, and
focusing on their growth,
how they work with you, how
they work with each other,
and those are the two biggest
things I think I've taken away
from working with Gary and
having him as my brother,
my business partner, and my mentor.
And my best friend.
- 'Preciate it bro, nice answer.
That is episode 12 of
the #AskGaryVee show,
this is the first week of football.
There'll be a lot of football
talk the rest of the week.
Get ready for it.
Raider Nation, you are going down.
You keep asking questions,
oh, wait!
I was about to close, but
the question of the day.
See, little rusty,
from all that kind of, vacation,
that was me looking at my tan,
if you were wondering
what the hell that was.
Question of the day.
Let's make it football.
What is your lock of the week?
What is your survival pool pick?
Your pick, no spread.
Survival pool pick.
Who's your lock for this week one
of the NFL season, my
favorite week of the year,
especially now that school's finished.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep trying to answer them.
(rhythmic hip-hop instrumental music)